I see you as a maybe packing as uh the
Uber is waiting yeah right exactly
exactly exactly putting it all together
exactly there's no folding it's just a
wait it's already folded thank you I
have a I have somebody that cleans the
house my mommy her mom cleans my house
and she folds everything and Mom does
all his stuff okay so she packs are you
pack I pack I don't want to pack okay I
pack before okay
that's insulting I know what a [__]
pack no but she
who does all the laundry and she folds
everything for him to choose from before
yeah I have thousands of t-shirts right
thousands thousands of things I know
and I'll and then I'll look and I'll go
hmm you know what I mean where am I
going so I'll I'll have that thought
processes right but yeah like when you
came here today I literally just woke up
just before I walked in yeah I ran down
here I opened I haven't even had my
coffee so I'm barely even here
that's why he was looking for you behind
you
the fact that I'm leaving Friday I'm
leaving Friday yeah my suitcase is out
already
really do you pack it yourself yeah yeah
I I I pack in in stages like uh oh wow
underwear maybe some socks tonight and
I'll start looking at okay I might be
golfing a couple golf pants and my
Wednesday night it's sealed it's
delivered in the garage ready to go yeah
that bothers me yeah I mean it [__]
bothers me because I'm gonna tell you
something buddy right that's some sort
of disorder you have it could be yeah
it's a disorder it could be yeah yeah I
mean the way you're like oh like
remember the shoes
what shoes you don't remember the shoes
oh yeah you remember the shoes yeah what
oh you yeah you told me to get rid of
shoes no you came to The Comedy Store
yeah this is probably 15 years ago I
don't know how long ago how do you know
this story I've told it before
yeah yeah many many times right and
there were like these Italian shoes you
bought they're like leather yeah but
they had a ninja cut out
from the toad of the rest of the [__]
I don't know
they were they were they were probably
pretty bad in your opinion right but
then I go I'll give you a hundred
dollars
if you throw those away yeah yeah yeah
yeah I don't remember if you did I did
not you didn't no I think in the story I
say that you did
in the story because I lie so I lie a
lot so in the store I say yeah he took
the hundred and went all Barefoot or
whatever it's just better story that way
it is the funnier story yeah but the way
it did happen I said keep your honored
I'm wearing it yeah yeah yeah I think
that's the way it happened when you get
to the hotel do you immediately unpack
everything's hung and then wow well
because he has button fancy silk [__]
from [__] France or whatever no no no
no no no yeah they crinkle they wrinkle
but this might this one we heard a
disorder kicks in for me okay
my suitcase yeah
I pack
to go home
folded beautiful so when you open the
suitcase when I come home yeah to the
naked eye you wouldn't know if I was
coming or coming
is it laundered
no sometimes if I'm staying longer than
expected I'll I'll clean the clothes
where I'm at but what I do the dirties I
put in the bag that they give you and I
put that in a kind of a separate section
if they're still clean stuff left over
you're just like my mom so she fold
folds them perfectly tiered in into a
hamper that's beautiful yeah so if I go
into your hotel like let's say you're in
a hotel for like four days yes on day
three if I walk in a hotel room would I
think to myself oh this is a clean room
yeah when I check it in oh real so
that's what it looks like mine looks
like an IED went off oh no I've been on
the road with you I know yeah just Taco
Bell I mean things against the wall like
a Taco on the wall like I don't give a
[__] yeah yeah it look it's this that's
it's a disaster I don't know how am I a
messy
like when we were dating was I
Bobby how did you date me I don't know
okay
the theory is that my mom was so OCD and
it drove me mad as a kid so you
represented this kind of freedom of like
I don't give a [__] and I'm just so
filthy that it gave me a sense of relief
but then you went you took it too far I
took it way too far yeah you took it too
far after a while I was like oof this
could be like a hepatitis issue like oh
yeah oh no it became like yeah
I feel like other people knew this about
the glue can we talk about the glue
behind you there's a whole bottle shelf
of glue the whole design
bottle we flew there the bottom but then
she used to put glue on your hands yeah